this week
on brian ross investigates the olympics
this year
already postponed once will depend
entirely on clothing 19.
should olympic athletes go to the head
of the line for a vaccine
shot and what about people behind bars
including the 911 terrorists at
guantanamo a leading medical ethics
professor says
absolutely yes they're a hot spot
and you want to make sure that you
protect the guards
the people who have to service the base
you don't want to have it incubated plus
he took on the vanica
and the catholic church's top cardinals
making headlines when he went after the
boy scouts
winning tens of millions for victims of
sexual abuse
so what's next now for controversial
lawyer jeff anderson
i have never ever in the 38 years i've
been in this world
been more alarmed about the safety of
children
he joins us tonight and this week's
winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices of
meteorite
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague at law and crime rhonda
schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the long line
for the covet 19
vaccine we've seen some people try to
cut in line
others trying to buy their way to the
head of the line and clearly
demand continues to outstrip supply
that's right brian the pace has been
picking up but so far only about
10 of americans have received their
first dose
and only about 3 percent have received
the second dose
and with all that there are questions
now that are huge ethical questions
should people behind bars including the
9 11 accused terrorists of guantanamo
should they get a clover 19 shot before
everyone else
it's an ethical question with very few
easy answers
we're joined now by professor arthur
kaplan the
founder of the division of bioethics at
the new york university school of
medicine
and professor kaplan thank you so much
for being here clothed 19th has
presented
so many ethical questions and choices
let me start by asking you one of the
hard ones
there was a proposal at one point to
give the vaccine to the 911 terrorists
at guantanamo
was that a smart move is that ethical it
is
and as much as we may despise those
people or
wonder why would we give them priority
over other americans who certainly have
been engaged in
terror look they're a hot spot
and you want to make sure that you
protect the guards
the people who have to service the base
you don't want to have an incubator i
feel the same way about prisoners and
jails they're not popular i get it
but the stigma shouldn't blind us to the
fact that you want to go
to the hot spots look um
even in prison settings we're not
condemning everybody to death
we're not saying you know because you
were convicted of embezzlement or uh
driving a getaway car you your life
isn't going to be protected
the combination of that plus protect the
community you know one of the biggest
outbreaks brian
in the u.s so far is in rural michigan
and i know why it's theirs because
that's where the state prison is
fascinating and in general how do you
think the ethical questions have been
handled by the
medical community by the trump
administration and now the biden
administration
somewhere between horrible and miserable
really and i say that because
the trump administration promised us if
you can remember
surplus vaccine remember they were
saying they had a surplus and it was in
warehouses
and we'd be able to use that biden shows
up there's no vaccine there's no surplus
nobody even knows how much vaccine there
is that's a bad
start to a vaccine rollout when you
don't even know what you've got
the rollout also got complicated by the
fact that we spent a long time arguing
about who should go first
people in nursing homes people in
prisons people in group homes
which by the way we continue to neglect
but it turns out the death rates
if you're intellectually impaired say
down syndrome is an adult
really high and healthcare workforce
argued and argued committees and so on
then we roll out and all of a sudden
all kinds of other people are getting
vaccinated not on that list
and people are angry rightly so saying
this rollout isn't fair and one other
point that i think we botched
and i'll put myself in the category of
people who didn't see it
straight it was great to have rules it's
great to roll out and say you go first
and you go second and
you're important as a health care worker
and we're going to do the nursing home
people that's great
what drives distribution of vaccine is
logistics
meaning if you tell people make
appointments by going on the web
and 80 year old people say i don't have
the web i don't have the internet
i don't even have a daughter-in-law to
help me i don't know how to use it
they're not going to get on and they're
not going to get vaccinated
or poor elderly in minority communities
aren't going to be there
if you say well we're going to roll it
out and we'll make it available
let's say i'll make this up at a big
civic center or sports stadium
mass vaccination that's nice but that
means you have to have a car
and it means you have to be able to take
a day to get there
you have no daycare no babysitter you
got to be on the job your boss doesn't
care why you're not there
you're going to get docked you're not
going
time and again we thought that what
would happen is we'd smoothly roll out
to the people who are top priority
what we see is where the vaccine is
distributed
and how you find it is just as important
to determining who's going to get it
as we approach the summer there's all
kinds of talks about getting
vaccinations for
athletes college and professional should
they get some kind of priority is there
a societal need to have
sports well i've been controversial a
little bit in saying i think we should
pay attention to prisoners even though
politicians don't like that
and i'm going to say i think we should
pay attention to some athletes and
here's why
i think a case can be made and i'll make
it that some athletes are essential
workers
if you're quarantined if you're isolated
if you're home
and you're looking for entertainment
it's part of mental health
i've watched more sports than ever and
i'm not the world's
biggest sports fan of all sports but i
find myself you know
watching uh division three hockey all of
a sudden because
it's kind of on and i'm still here and
uh
i think it can make the case that pro
athletes
the olympics they may be useful to us
not because they're deserving but
because they give us
pleasure they give us an outlet they
give us release i don't think it applies
to every athlete i don't think we're
talking necessarily about you know every
high school and so on
but i do think as much as people argue
about
what's important in distributing vaccine
we tend to look at
who's going to die but i also think we
need to look soon
at quality of life and so they may fit
in there
i think the olympics may happen if we
use vaccine that way and i think
the world may actually wind up saying
you know what
maybe a few less people who are delivery
people got vaccinated but
that was meaningful to us help get us
through
let me ask you a question finally on
global ethics is it fair for
america united states and other wealthy
countries to take as much as they can
without thinking about
the poorer countries of the world yeah
so
if we vaccinate ourselves or germany
vaccinates germany or whoever
that's what i call vaccine nationalism i
think i coined that term
um and it says put your own country
first i'm a defender of that to a degree
what i mean is i think you have to take
care of the neediest people
in your country first i sometimes think
of it like
if you're on the airplane they give you
an instruction if the mass comes down
put it on yourself before you help
others i think there's a version of that
that makes sense for any country
take care of your healthcare workforce
protect your elderly
get your essential workers done once you
do that
then i think you have an obligation to
start to think about helping
other countries who can't do it and that
could be either sharing our supply or
buying vaccine for them so up to a point
i think we should vaccinate our own
neediest people first the people we need
to get the economy going
then i do think we should try to help
others
and you see that happening though
political sense no
not yet i still think right now most
politicians are like
we're going to vaccinate every single
breathing american before we start
thinking about
other countries i don't think that's
smart one reason it isn't smart
is it isn't even prudent you don't want
those countries blowing back on us with
continued uh outbreaks of new mutations
you want to
take care of them too it's prudent is it
fair to say
we're not safe until everyone else is
safe too i do
watching the mutation rate on this virus
which is going faster than i thought it
was going to
nobody's safe until we tamp it out
everywhere all right
professor arthur kaplan from the new
york university school of medicine
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight thanks for having me
coming up next the lawyer who took on
the vatican and the boy scouts of
america
over widespread sexual abuse joins us to
talk about
his next big case you're watching brian
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network
well if you want to get the attention of
the vatican or the leaders of the boy
scouts of america
all you have to do is mention the name
of one american lawyer jeff anderson
rhonda
that's right brian and over his long
career
jeff anderson has taken on thousands of
clients
survivors of sex abuse and received tens
of millions in settlements
from the catholic church the boy scouts
and even the vatican
and now he's on to his next big case
against a widely uh
spattered church in this country the
light of the world church
led by a man who calls himself the
apostle
we are here today standing with social
to sound the alarm
and to expose the culture
and the predators that are active as we
speak
not just in trafficking not just
in sexual assault not just in the
cover-up of it
but in the silencing of anybody that
would speak against them
i have never ever in the 38 years i've
been in this work been more alarmed
about the safety of children
than in this situation for the first 30
years of my life
i was taught to believe that my body my
mind
my soul belonged to mundo
because it was the will of god
from the age of nine i was taught
that my own family and community
that my eternal soul depended on me
sexually pleasing losing apostles
for nearly 22 years i was made to work
for
travel for life for
and give my body to an organization
that saw me as nothing more than a
source of profit
and sexual pleasure
and we're joined now by jeff anderson
from his office and jeff thank you much
for being here tell us a little bit
about social martin
and why you think this case is such a
important one
what an extraordinarily courageous
woman courageous survivor
and i say that because she is one
of many thousands now
who not only have shared the secret of
sexual abuse
and exploitation but she
has chosen and had the courage to stand
up not just for herself
but to stand up against a very
powerful religious organization
called the light of the world alolus del
mundo
and its so-called apostle
who exercises enormous power
and against that power she has shined a
light
i having brought suit by having
shared her secret and had the courage
to tell the truth and thus shine the
light
so that other kids can be protected
but an extraordinary woman who is among
thousands of survivors
with whom i and we have had the
privilege to now
work with for
almost four decades
as you know the apostle san joaquin
garcia
has pleaded guilty to more than 20
criminal charges in his awaiting trial
in california why the civil lawsuit now
you're going after the church and him
yeah he's actually pled not guilty
and is awaiting trial and being held
on very high bail as we speak and
the civil suit has been brought by her
and by us because it really
is an opportunity to bring more light
and more truth to what he and those
around him have done to
so many for so long using their power
using their position
to not only exploit children
and vulnerable adults but to allow so
many
else around them to do it
and this civil suit brought by her
and others like her really brings light
and truth to bear
in a way that a criminal case can't
because the criminal case
focuses on the offender the civil
case focuses on the culture that
permits the offender to
engage in the criminal conduct
and the cover-up and concealment of it
and thus the civil suits that both
social martin has brought
and the other survivors with whom we
work bring
and continue to bring really protect
kids in the future
and help those jeff have been hurt
a question for you jeff from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
and jeff you're so well known for the
cases that you brought against the
catholic church
is this are you finding is this a church
or is this a different kind of
organization and are there special
perils here
many of the survivors that we've spoken
to have told us they're very afraid to
speak out
well you know this journey for me
working with survivors began in the
early 80s
and the first suit brought against the
catholic bishops in america
and exposed their concealment
and cover-up of it the case by social
martin
uh parallels uh that uh
effort that began for us almost four
decades ago
but the thing that makes this so
stunning
after all these years is the peril
that is so present in real time
right now and that means that what
he the apostle and that culture
which calls themselves a church that
more appropriately
resembles a cult in any
definition of cult applies here
power concentrated and you figure loses
it
why do these cults of this widespread
sexual abuse what's at the heart
of it why do we keep seeing so much
well i think at the heart of this cult
and this particular case
is a concentration of power using
divinity
and using the power
that they have over the souls and the
care of the souls
and in addition they use fear
and they use intimidation and they use
money and with the power
of their divinity and the power
that they enjoy over the souls of these
adults who join them uh and they
exercise it
uh and they also use um
intimidation intimidation all right
jeff anderson right
all right jeff anderson thank you so
much for joining us continue to
do the good work you've been doing
that's made your name so well known and
so feared by people in power
jeff anderson thanks much thank you
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the editors of
media but what they had to say about lou
dobbs
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by the editor-in-chief of
meteorite aidan mclaughlin and
meteorite like the long crime trial
network all part of the dan abrams media
company
and aiden the winner and loser both
weeks uh both in the same place
at fox business news with larry kudlow
in and lou dobbs out
larry kudlow who it was announced a
couple weeks ago was joining fox news
as a contributor has now landed his own
show at fox business
um you'll recall he was an economic
advisor to president donald trump
before that he uh served uh as a
host for cnbc and was kind of a
financial pundit so he's now back in
television
he's hosting a show on fox business in
the sort of prime market hour of 4 p.m
and that comes as lou dobbs who is
previously the top-rated host
at fox business had his show cancelled
abruptly on friday
in a pretty surprising announcement um
it was surprising that
fox business showed no sign that they
were abandoning lou dobbs despite
him pushing a series of conspiracy
theories about the election
but the move did come a day after
smartmatic which is one of the
election voting systems companies that
has been the subject of conspiracy
theories surrounding the 2020 election
filed a 2.7 billion dollar lawsuit
against fox corporation
and it named lou dobbs in that lawsuit
as one of the hosts who had been
spreading the conspiracy theories about
the election
and aiden as you know fox has sort of
denied it was connected to the lawsuit
but
dobbs was off the air thursday never had
a chance to say goodbye always a bad
sign when
someone's leaving exactly so fox news is
saying that this is
one of their standard programming moves
in the aftermath of the election that
doesn't make a lot of sense
uh mu dobbs was the top rated host on
fox business why they would cancel his
show
a day after they they received a 2.7
billion lawsuit
from a company that says it was defamed
by lou dobbs
that i think is clearly we can assume
that that is the reason why he was let
go
the question that remains though is that
there were a couple of other hosts that
were named in that lawsuit
maria bartoromo and jeanine pirro who
also pushed false claims about
smartmatic and about the 2020 election
those hosts it's not clear that anything
is going to happen to them so it's it is
a little unclear why dobbs was
selected uh cancellation and not those
other fox news
and quickly and 15 seconds left what's
next for lou dobbs do you think
you know uh newsmax and oan have already
signaled that they'd be open for him to
join them
he's getting on there i don't know if he
he has much of a career left he seems
pretty content to be
um you know bashing fox on his twitter
feed for now but uh we'll keep our eyes
open
and so far he's been tweeting out
retweets that are critical of his old
boss is at fox so we'll see
aida mclaughlin thank you so much for
joining us good to have you as always on
the program
and thanks to all of you for tuning in
tonight to watch brian ross investigates
and thanks to the great strath at a law
and crime for getting us on the air and
off the air without a hitch
[Music]
you